affaire du sang contaminé vers une mise
hors de cause des trois anciens
ministres laurent fabius
edmond hervé georgina dufoix
la cour de cassation confirme la peine
de six mois de prison ferme pour bernard
tapie dans la sphère du fossé à bernard
tapie qui est notre invité ce soir sur
ce plateau une île artificielle pour
éviter les atterrissages dangereux le
nouvel aéroport de hong kong a été
inaugurée aujourd'hui par le président
chinois yang et blanc
france italie les quarts de finale de la
coupe du monde c'est pour demain les
français comptent sur zidane les
italiens sur leur buteur
vieri l'exploit pour la française
nathalie tauziat elle est en finale du
tournoi de tennis de wimbledon
elle rencontrera la tchèque novotna
samedi après midi
madame monsieur bonsoir dix ans après le
début de la sphère du sang contaminé par
le virus du sida lé la cour de cassation
dans un arrêt publié aujourd'hui rend
improbable le renvoi des trois anciens
ministres socialistes devant la cour de
justice de la république
laurent fabius edmond hervé georgina
dufoix en effet la cour de cassation
conclut que pour qu'il y ait crime
d'empoisonnement
il faut une volonté de tuer la seule
connaissance de cette possibilité
n'étant pas suffisant dominique
verdeilhan philip lee le visage grave
olivier du plessis le président de
l'association des transfusés redoutait
cette décision de la cour de cassation
saisie d'un dossier criminel
en marge de la sphère du sang contaminé
elle permet aux magistrats de donner une
définition juridique de l'empoisonnement
la seule connaissance du pouvoir
mortelle de la substance administrée et
qu'ils les juges ne suffit pas à
caractériser l'intention homicide
autrement dit l'empoisonnement nécessite
une intention de tuer une définition qui
pour les hémophiles et les transfusés
remet en question les poursuites
judiciaires contre les médecins élimine
cette décision la cour de cassation
aujourd'hui sous des dehors anodin pour
une affaire qui malgré tout est si belle
ferme organise une amnistie sanitaire
qui condamne les développements
judiciaires de l'affairé du sang
contaminé dans le volet médical ce sont
31 praticiens dont michel garretta qui
sont mises en examen pour empoisonnement
dans le volet politique ce sont trois
anciens ministres qui sont poursuivis
pour complicité d'empoisonnement
avec cette nouvelle définition les
avocats de la défense ne pouvait rêver
mieux comme argument pour demander un
non lieu mais la justice est pas la
réponse à l'éruption la justice et la
pression fait la position en droit nous
lisons n'y a pas de responsabilité
pénale
parlons simplement effectivement restons
sûreté sur les principes essentiels
quel que soit même s'ils sont dans une
situation parfois extrêmes de tram que
l'on peut comprendre la décision
d'aujourd'hui ne stoppe pas les
procédures mais elle les pièges de
l'intérieur on en arrive à une situation
paradoxale des juges continue
d'instruire de se poser la question y at
il eu un empoisonnement de leur côté les
victimes connaissent déjà la réponse
c'est non c'est encore la cour de
cassation qui s'est exprimé ce matin
dans la sphère du phocéa le yacht de
bernard tapie et la rejeter son pourvoi
en conséquence bernard tapie devrait
normalement purgée six nouveaux mois de
prison ferme mais ses avocats espèrent
obtenir la confusion des peines avec un
jugement précédent qui l'avait conduit à
effectuer lui mois derrière les barreaux
bernard tapie est notre invité ce soir
mais d'abord le rappel des faits l'idée
caroff jean-jacques le garrec bernard
tapie battant des records avec le procès
à c'était il y a dix ans aujourd'hui se
voyait le ramène à quelques encablures
des portes d'une prison avec une
condamnation définitive à un an et demi
de détention dont six mois ferme pour
fraude fiscale
la cour de cassation a mis un point
final à cette affaire où plus de 12
millions de francs ont été soustraits au
fisc
pour bernard tapie c'était le dernier
recours mais son avocat ne désespère pas
de trouver dans la procédure de quoi
éviter une incarcération
normalement il va en prison reste à
savoir si il pourra obtenir du juge de
l'application des peines une décision de
confusion de peine totale partielle par
rapport aux autres peines qui vient ont
été infligées qui date déjà fumé car la
prison bernard tapie a déjà goûté 165
jours durant une condamnation pour
corruption dans l'affairé du match
truqué om contre valenciennes la peine
deux ans de prison dont huit mois ferme
la casquette de patron du club
marseillais lui vaut une autre
condamnation en juin dernier devant une
cour d'appel
cette fois pour abus de confiance sur
les comptes de l'om
trois ans de prison avec sursis bernard
tapie le chef d'entreprise lui aussi a
été jugé c'était il ya deux ans une
condamnation dont il n'a pas fait appel
pour abus de biens sociaux aux dépens de
la société testud deux ans de prison
avec sursis à ce feuilleton judiciaire
le juge eva joly a ajouté un dernier
chapitre en 1996 en mettant l'homme
d'affaires en examen pour banqueroute et
détournements d'actifs dans la sphère du
crédit lyonnais et bernard tapie bonsoir
c'est pas du tout dans la sphère du
crédit lyonnais mais ça fait rien on
vient d'entendre le compte rendu de la
cour de cassation six mois de prison
ferme que vous allez sans doute être
obligé de faire dans le livre que vous
venez d'écrire librement vous dit si
vous êtes d'agir et que vous n'avez
jamais imaginé d'être frappé par cette
épreuve
l'incarcération vous sera intolérable
est ce que vous imaginez pouvoir
retourner en présent je suis bien obligé
de l'imaginer même si effectivement on a
cet après midi expliqué qu'il existait
encore des voies de recours non pas sur
le jugement lui-même qui est maintenant
définitif mais sur l'application de
cette peine comment je vais réagir
je sais pas parce que la première fois
j'étais convaincu jallet jallet accepté
ce traitement relativement bien j'étais
parti forge le croyait et j'ai tenu deux
heures le temps que j'aperçois monfils
derrière
les barreaux du fourgon qui pleurait qui
m'a fait à ce moment-là perdre tout
goûter tous sens delà du respect de moi
même puisque je me suis transformée en
une loque
donc je sais pas comment je réagirais si
ça arrive encore et il faudra bien se
dire qu'on a pas on n'a pas le choix
une décision de justice elle est allée
ce qu'elle est on n'a pas la contester
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
gagner du temps est-ce que ça servira à
quelque chose ou bien non justement ce
le temps n'arrange rien le l'avocat
général de la cour de cassation avait
dit que effectivement il n'y avait pas
de ma part d'intentions malveillantes et
y avait pas non plus de mauvaise foi et
aujourd'hui la cour de cassation pour
mon jugement un mois a dit que la
mauvaise foi était pas obligatoire pour
qu'on sanctionne quand même alors
j'aurais bien aimé quand même juste une
seconde mais tiennent compte que dans ce
fossé à puisqu'on a parlé j'ai vraiment
choisi toutes les voix contraires à
l'intérêt financier puisque je les ai
mis sous pavillon français alors vous
savez les trois quarts des grands
bateaux mais mais sous pavillon étranger
j'ai pas voulu profiter des lois pons
qui permettent de défiscaliser la
totalité de l'investissement
j'ai utilisé un équipage de marine
marchande française
cela ne vous est peut-être et était mal
conseillé ou il ya quand même eu
tentative de dissimulation
non il ya des amortissements compas et
effet la cour de cassation a estimé elle
que le jugement était correct donc y'a
rien à en dire
il ya quelques instants bernard tapie on
a évoqué l' affaire du sang contaminé
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
puis elle a évoqué votre affaire vous
semblez dire en permanence dans ce livre
d'ailleurs qu' il y adeux justice elle
qui sapent il s'applique aux politiques
et puis celles qui s'appliquent à
bernard tapie à qui on laisse rien
passer
savvis pas du tout cette procédure là ça
vise le fait que quand on a de multiples
activités et qu'on peut pas les assumer
tout et qu'on les fait par personne
interposée
les magistrats ne juge que les affaires
qu'on leur présente et soyez absolument
certain 7
disculpe de rien des insuffisances des
infractions toutes les fautes qu'on peut
commettre mais le fait est que quand on
fait beaucoup de choses si on cherche
beaucoup on trouve un peu et c'est dans
la volonté de chercher et trouver
davantage que dans le traitement qui m'a
été fait que je trouve des injustices le
bernard tapie d'aujourd'hui ne ressemble
pas du tout quand on vous voit à celui
d'il ya un an ou deux est ce que vous
avez compris que votre attitude
peut-être a indisposé la justice j'ai
compris j'ai fait symbolique à un moment
on me présentait comme celui qui
incarnait la victoire
le bonheur la réussite c'était c'était
les années qui voulait ça il fallait le
faire j'ai été choisi pour sa malgré moi
je méritais peut-être pas tous ces
honneurs et le fait est que quand la
roue a tourné parce que c'était plus la
mode
on a utilisé de la même manière avec
autant d'outrance l'envi de démontrer
que j'avais tous les péchés du monde
comme avant on disait excessivement que
gerry boulet toute l'équipe
un certain nombre de personnes qui ne
vous sont pas forcément hostiles bernard
tapie et je considère que vous avez joué
et que vous avez perdu et vous vous
dites on lui dans le livre entre les
lignes j'ai été roulée ne range pas été
roulé mais et mais je méritais pas en
tout état de cause si on met en
perspective les fautes commises et les
sanctions donné bon jeu le 18 mois de
prison ferme pour un match de football
s'était jamais arrivé dans toute
l'histoire du football et je vous
répliqué qu'il ya des voleurs de poules
qui sont en prison ribes là faut pas les
y mettre bernard tapie il ya quelque
chose que personne n'a remarqué jusqu'à
présent dans ce livre c'est que vous y
parlez religion n'imagine pas bernard
tapie parlant religion c'est quelque
chose que vous avez découvert en prison
je me trompe
ah non non je suis croyant depuis très
longtemps simplement d'abord je crois
que le la foi est quelque chose de très
intime qui est une relation personnelle
comme l'amour d'une femme on parle pas
de l'amour qu'on a pour sa femme on se
contente de dire qu'on est vous avez ont
découvert la région elle vous a aidé en
prison boulade elle m'a aidé
considérablement mais je n'ai pas
découvert en prison j'en ai parlé en
prison parce qu'à certains moments
décisifs et
et à certains moments de peur de crainte
de doute et de difficultés de surmonter
ont fait appel à ses vrais croyants ça
peut être dieu c'était mon cas mais ce
après d'autres croyances il n'y a pas
que celle-là
là j'en avais jamais parlé pardonnez moi
parce que parce que ce qui compte c'est
l'amour qu'on a pour l'eau c'est pas la
certitude que l'autre vous m
alors le passé de bernard tapie on
connaît ça a été des affaires le sport
la politique et l'avenir de verdun puis
ce sera quoi bah en fonction de l'état
dans lequel je serai au moment où je
pourrais envisager l'avenir avec
sérénité et tranquillité ce sera
sûrement de nouveaux certaines de ses
activités dans laquelle j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir qui touche au sport
qui coûte touche à l'économie à
l'exception de la politique la politique
vous l'avez pris en grippe vous avez dit
moi qui était si fort en affaire je
n'avais rien à y faire je suis tombé
dans un monde que j'ignorais vraiment
pas en grippe parce que je crois que
c'est vraiment l'activité humaine la
plus gratifiante et la plus noble mais
je crois qu'il faut être débarrassés
tout autre à la fois activités surtout
tout autre moyen de pression parce qu'on
est très fragilisée quand on fait des
affaires
quand on fait du football ou tout autre
donc il faut ne faire que ça je crois
que ça justifie qu'on ne fasse que ça et
moi je crois pas que dans toute ma vie
je n'ai eu envie de faire qu'une seule
chose j'étais gourmands des activités
que je savais faire et je voulais les
embrasser tout pas tort j'aurais dû être
moins ambitieux bernard tapie si vous
avez beaucoup de soucis aujourd'hui mais
c'est vous êtes un amateur de football
demain la france italie on comprendrait
pas je ne vous pose pas la question
d'être quand même un de nos spécialistes
un homme qui aime le sport le football
voyez quoi je vais pas vous dire ce que
je vois je vous dire ce que je voudrais
je voudrais que la france gagne et vous
savez la charnière centrale a pas à part
toute la colonne vertébrale à paris dan
qui est 25e et que des chantres de
sailly barthez sont marseille et avec
marseille on a toujours battu les
italiens toujours on les a toujours
éliminé
espérons que ça donnera l'exemple merci
bernard tapie j'appelle le titre de
votre livre librement bernard tapie aux
éditions plon
merci 5 cyclotouristes tué hier soir et
quatre autres blessés grièvement dans
une collision avec une voiture près de
niort dans les deux sèvres la voiture
roulait
probablement une vitesse excessive
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète et l'alcootest s'est révélé
négatif
françois privat philippe ritter cinq
morts quatre blessés graves
la sortie à bicyclette sur une route
départementale des deux-sèvres tourner
au drame lorsque le conducteur d'un
monospace de type scénic perd le
contrôle de son véhicule et couches
possible
l'article est inouï et peut-être ont-ils
un peu vite
il a dû être surpris par ce groupe de
cyclistes venant en sens inverse
lors de son interrogatoire le conducteur
du monospace affirmé rouler aux environs
de 90 km sur route est étroite alors que
la pluie tombait par intermittence ou
vers des hypothèses car les opprimés
première explication réflexe contre broc
alors il est indemne
le premier et le dernier puis tous les
autres touches qu'on va probablement
retenir c'est une vitesse inadaptée aux
circonstances c'est à dire inadapté à la
route inadapté à la présence d'autres
usagers en l'occurrence les cyclistes et
inadapté aussi en raison de la pluie à
l'hôpital de niort trois personnes sont
toujours dans un état jugé sérieux et
préoccupant des biens sur leur gravité
leur côté exceptionnellement grave et le
nombre de décédé d'emblée laisse
supposer qu'il ya eu un impact d'une
très grande violence
mis en examen pour homicide involontaire
par imprudence le conducteur de la
voiture vient d'être placé sous contrôle
judiciaire
son permis de conduire a été aussitôt
suspendu or même des circonstances de
l'accident d'hier soir il y à des
conseils de sécurité à observer
lorsqu'on circule à vélo que l'on soit
seul ou en groupe reportage dans la
région de niort justement qui compte une
trentaine d'associations de
cyclotourisme pascalou c'est bon josé
boulesteix l'accident grave ils ne l'ont
jamais connu mais il y pense tous les
jours comme ceux de la manip les
cyclotouristes de la sppt de niort route
au moins une fois par semaine ils sont
bien équipés et prêchent pour le bon
comportement du cycle
respecter comme les voitures comme les
véhicules au code de la route première
fois roulé suivant l'état des routes
voulait couper mais rouler en file
indienne selon l'état des routes le code
est très clair pas plus de deux
cyclistes de front le casque élégance on
recommande
voilà pour la théorie le cas où les
automobilistes ces cartes
consciencieusement en clignotant et où
les cyclistes ne roule pas en paquet
mais raymond c'est que la réalité n'est
pas si rose
il roule depuis 40 ans et depuis 40 ans
une peste le fait que charmeux bataille
et j'y mets toi à droite mais toi à
droite vient une voiture voiture
derrière je klaxonne
parce que les voitures klaxonnent pas
non plus et fait du vélo au canada vous
avez une voiture qui peut vous suivre
pendant 10 km sans vous doubler si elle
peut pas pas fait un mètre et le
passeport
tandis que chez nous c'est pas comme ça
elle peut passer sur les pédales et le
pas sur les pédales par pudeur ils ont
préféré ne pas revenir sur l'accident
d'hier mais reconnaissent qu'ils
auraient pu être à la place des victimes
ça ne les empêchera pas de rouler tout
l'été passion oblige en retirant son
projet de réforme du scrutin des
élections européennes il neige aux pains
connaît son premier revers politique
sérieux d'après les premières réactions
ce recul tient plutôt à la contestation
d'une partie de sa propre majorité
communiste et verts aux objections de
l'opposition jean baptiste président il
faut changer le mode de scrutin il faut
le faire bien entendu le plus vite
possible de façon à ce que le nouveau
mode puisse s'appliquer aux prochaines
élections européennes sur cette réforme
ils étaient tous d'accord de l'elysée à
matignon lionel jospin avait même fait
plancher son gouvernement
un nouveau dispositif était prévu
l'élection des députés européens non
plus dans une circonscription mais dans
huit régions
objectif affiché rapprocher les élus
européens de leurs électeurs pourtant
les alliés verts et communistes des
socialistes s'y oppose la réforme leur
ferait perdre des sièges la droite
elles redoutent d'étaler ses divisions
dans chaque région le projet de loi est
pourtant bouclé prêt à être voté la
semaine prochaine à l'assemblée
mais le gouvernement fait ses comptes
faute de majorité le projet de loi est
retiré il faut prendre en compte
effectivement le pignon des formations
de la majorité
c'est ce qu'a fait le premier ministre
non seulement ce n'est pas une les âmes
mais ça va dans le bon sens il est
dommage que certains dans la majorité
plurielle et préférer des intérêts
partisans ça peut arriver même à gauche
et puis qu'à droite
les dirigeants du rpr et de l'udf se
soit calé sur une opposition
systématique la droite justement se
félicite aujourd'hui du retrait du texte
et des dissensions dans la majorité sur
les européennes
lionel jospin opérer un repli tactique
mais faute de réformes
gauche et droite vont aller divisé aux
européennes c'est dans un an toujours
l'entreprise aéronautique européenne
airbus dame le pion en ce moment à
boeing depuis le début de cette année
elle multiplie les bonnes affaires avec
une dernière commande de la compagnie
américaine us airways
cet airbus a330 ferme et une prévision
de 30
au total le gouvernement japonais a
annoncé aujourd'hui un traitement de
cheval pour juguler la crise financière
et bancaire de nombreux établissements
sont en faillite avec les conséquences
que l'on sait reportage jean-paul
chapelle patrick des muses
dans ce restaurant chic de tokyo il
régalait ses meilleurs clients sans
compter aujourd'hui le golden boys de la
finance n'a plus droit aux notes de
frais la banque qui l'employait a réduit
ses effectifs depuis quatre mois
taka est au chômage
quand je suis sortie de l'université il
y avait dix offres d'emploi pour un
diplômé c'était la prospérité
aujourd'hui j'ai 35 ans et je suis
inquiet on parle d'une reprise l'an
prochain mais je n'y crois pas taka
n'est pas l'unique victime de la crise
financière le 24 novembre dernier le pdg
de yamaha qui présente des excuses
publiques il n'a pu éviter la faillite
d'une des plus grandes sociétés de
bourse faute et ses employés ne sont pas
en cause
je me sens responsable de tout ce qui
arrive du jamais vu au japon
huit mille personnes sont licenciées les
actionnaires panique pour la société
générale à tokyo c'est l'occasion rêvée
elle rachète une partie des dépouilles
la gestion de portefeuille pour les
banques étrangères il ya d'excellentes
affaires à faire c'est un pays c'est un
pays précurseur plan économique mais
c'est un pays émergent sur plan
financier et pour les compagnies
étrangères il faut avoir accès à ce qui
est le deuxième bassin des parts du
monde plus de 5000 milliards de francs
le quart de l'épargné mondiale est
détenu par les japonais un véritable
pactole à condition que la crise de
confiance ne se propage pas au reste de
la planète
si le japon va si c'est la deuxième
puissance mondiale
on risque d'aller vers des grandes
turbulences financières qui toucheront
très rapidement les états unis
d'amérique
et puis ensuite l'union européenne et
une partie de notre croissance sera très
certainement très ébréchée par une crise
grave japonais conscient du danger le
gouvernement nippon prépare un plan de
sauvetage
l'état devrait purger un circuit
financier qui a trop longtemps spéculé
sur l'immobilier a cumulé les placements
douteux et encouragé la corruption
le système bancaire japonais dans son
ensemble rappelle par bien des aspects
le scandale de notre crédit lyonnais
mais en 25 fois pire ici les pertes
potentielles atteignent 2500 milliards
de francs et au bout du compte c'est le
contribuable japonais qui devra payer la
facture
au lendemain du premier anniversaire de
la restitution de hong kong à la chine a
été inauguré le nouvel aéroport terminé
les atterrissages périlleux entre les
immeubles les nouvelles pistes ont été
construites sur une île artificielle
les premiers passagers allaient utiliser
auront été le président chinois et le
président américain will win
isabelle bechler ou prises dans le coin
ils sont 350 mille habitants de la
presqu'île de kaloum à vivre sous la
voie d' approche de jumbo qui
atterrissent 17 heures sur 24 à kai tak
350 millions de kong est condamné au
stress et aux boules quiès sauf les fous
de l'observation des avions ce qui
relève chaque jour les numéros
d'immatriculation des appareils et get
l'accident appareil photo au poing assez
régulièrement il ya dressé chimique
unique parce que l'approché très
difficile de virage est très sec et
lancement et quand ils y adhérent ou de
grosses pluies selon le point de vue
l'approché intéressant tout ange reuzeau
panthers après
et particulièrement en cas typhon d'un
point à travailler ça peut tourner très
mal
à quelques jours de la fermeture les
curieux viennent pour quelques derniers
frissons saturé décibels c'est notre
dernière chance d'observer les avions
alors on en profite
l'aéroport est donc se déplacer de 30 km
des travaux colossaux ont été entrepris
pour gagner sur la mer à partir de
l'îlot de cech la coque sans compter les
infrastructures routières et
ferroviaires pour y accéder un
investissement de 120 milliards de
francs qui paraît bien lourd en ces
temps de crise l'aviation civile en asie
encore de très beaux jours devant elle
la crise asiatique n'est que passagère
la tendance de fond et au développement
à long terme
nous avons été très prudents dans le
montage financier annuel et cet aéroport
sera rentable prévu pour faire transiter
80 millions de passagers en 2050
le nouvel aéroport à une capacité
immédiate de 35 millions de voyageurs
dans sa première franche
il sera opérationnel le 6 juillet après
une performance de déménagement est
clair dans la nuit qui précède ce sera
donc clairement une nuit de folie
tempéré de rigueur militaire 30
mouvements d'avions cargos au moins 70
navires et des camions par centaines
pour déménager l'aéroport en six heures
de temps vers cette nouvelle
infrastructure
là les derniers détails viennent d'être
tout juste terminés pour le premier
anniversaire de la rétrocession de hong
kong à la chine
alger cet après midi une manifestation
contre la loi d'arabisation de pays
promulgué hier a été réprimée par la
police
les manifestants dénoncent et en même
temps le pouvoir et les assassins du gia
reportage thierry thulliez bruno gironde
ils voulaient marcher sur la présidence
en hommage à l' us matoub
ils ont été arrêtés sans ménagement
un cordon policier l'interdiction de
filmer les forces de police dont
l'action est dénoncée dans les
organisateurs la seule constance de son
grade ce que sont les envoyés des
fenêtres pour tabasser des jeunes
manifestants qui sont venus manifester
d'une manière très vite aux cris de
génie à pouvoir assassin un deuxième
groupe de manifestants arrivent ce sont
des militants du rcd parti d'opposition
laïque très bien implanté en kabylie
leur manifestation est interdite alors
ils se rassemblent devant le siège de
leur parti
un défi au pouvoir ils font du refus de
l'arabisation une question de principe
m
saïd saadi le leader du rcd ne prend
même plus de précautions de langage
le pouvoir est devenue sa science et
religion après didier ouzou les partis
de l'opposition finck de mobiliser alger
la capitale où vit une importante
communauté berbère une mobilisation dont
le point d'orgue est prévue le 5 juillet
jour de la fête de l'indépendance et de
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi sur
l'arabisation le premier ministre
anglais tony blair en visite en irlande
du nord au lendemain de l'installation
du premier gouvernement autonome
l'ulster qui connaît depuis quelques
jours une série d' incendies dans des
églises catholiques d'origine criminelle
que l'on attribue le plus souvent à des
extrémistes protestants en france le
flnc canal historique revendique
l'attentât contre un bureau de poste
c'était dans la nuit d'hier à marseille
ainsi que trois autres explosions dans
l'île cette fois-ci gilles millet
collaborateurs de l'événement du jeudi a
été mise en examen pour recel et
violation de secret de l'instruction
nous allons unir dans un instant mais
d'abord à propos de la régularisation
des immigrés clandestins le ministre de
l'intérieur a indiqué aujourd'hui que
tous les recours des candidats seront
examinées ceux qui ont été déboutés en
première instance vont être réexaminés
donc dans les préfectures
j'en reviens à gilles millet
collaborateurs de l'événement du jeudi
mise en examen pour recel et violation
du secret d'instruction dans le cadre
d'une enquête sur les événements en
corse michele finn valérie ermite simon
phase i est président d'une caisse
locale du crédit agricole en corse son
nom est cité dans le rapport de
l'inspection générale des finances pour
un prêt d'un million 3 jamais remboursés
ce reportage a été diffusé sur france 3
il est signé gilles millet journaliste
spécialisé dans les affaires corses
ce jour là gilles millet est venu voir
simon phase i pour lui demander de
réagir aux accusations formulées dans le
rapport de l'hygiène vous nous expliquer
pourquoi il assume entièrement
pourquoi vous trouvera juste cette
accusation trois semaines après la
diffusion de ce reportage simon fin de
vie il est arrêté en marge de l'enquêté
sur l'assassinât du préfet erignac
en perquisitionnant chez lui les
enquêteurs découvrent le rapport de
l'igpn simon phase iib affirme que c'est
le journaliste qui le lui a donné mardi
la division antiterroriste interpelle
gilles millet à 6 heures du matin et
perquisitionnent son domicile voilà
encore savez ce document par ailleurs ce
document je vous le rappelle a été
publiée en partie dans le monde est
pratiquement intégral je crois qu'avec
ce presse donc j'étais à peu atone et
conviennent m'embêter mois en
perquisitionnant les enquêteurs ont
découvert d'autres documents de police
bien plus confidentiels ils saisissent
alors le carnet d adresses et les notes
de gilles millet leur objectif savoir
qui a pu fournir ces documents aux
journalistes en un mot trouvé ces
sources
ça me fait très peur ce qui s'est passé
là parce que ça veut dire que demain
n'importe quel juge
mais pourra pour a perquisitionné et
journaliste prend de leur prendre leurs
notes essayer de savoir quelles sont
leurs contacts
essayez de 2 de leur prendre leur lors
l'essence même de leur métier
l'ensemble des journalistes a réagi très
vivement à l'interpellation de gilles
millet la protection des sources est
garantie par la loi
elle est avant tout l'assurance de
pouvoir informer librement remungol dans
le morbihan 900 habitants son maire a
trouvé une recette originale pour tenter
de repeupler sa commune il vend à 1
francs le mètre carré de terrain à
condition que l'on construise et que
l'on vienne y habiter frédéric renaud
lavillenie guen il n'y a plus du tout
terrains disponibles nous ne sommes pas
dans une agence immobilière mais à la
mairie 50 coups de téléphone par jour et
déjà 200 dossiers en attente
tous veulent acquérir ici un coin de
bretagne il faut dire que pour attirer
de nouvelles familles le maire propose
des terrains un prix imbattable 700 m² à
1 franc ça vous fait sept enfants sur
lesquels vous pouvez construire de ce
côté ici vous avez une partie de cette
partie là dedans si vous voulez qu'ils
sont déjà vendus les constructions vont
commencer au mois de septembre
et ça donnera ce que vous voyez derrière
là bas au moins de 3 ans 15 familles
avec enfants ont saisi l'occasion pour
s'installer
on avait à plus ou moins approcher quand
même
mais bon balle à olaf réalisé comme le
terrain n'était pas cher brp en a
profité pour l'acheter tous sont ainsi
pu devenir propriétaire pour moins de
500 mille francs
l'opération atteint son objectif fixé
une population qui avait tendance à
déserter cette zone rurale pour ce fait
la commune 6e mais à des jeunes couples
avec des enfants ça revivre un petit peu
depuis 30 ans le village perdait
régulièrement des habitants en trois ans
il en a gagné une centaine de quoi
maintenir les deux écoles et même créer
une nouvelle classe quand vous vous
promenez sur le sur le coin à la sortie
des écoles
les mamans avec des poussettes ça c'est
pour nous c'est fantastique quoi cet
enthousiasme ne gagne d'autres communes
aux alentours plusieurs villages copie
déjà l'exemple romain goal après les
éboulements de terrain du début de
semaine les habitants de bourg d'oisans
qui avaient été évacuées préventivement
de leurs habitations ont été autorisés
ce soir à rentrer chez eux tout nouveau
donjon est pour le moment provisoirement
écarté le premier ministre lionel jospin
en visite à sienne en italie aujourd'hui
où il assiste en compagnie du président
du conseil italien romano prodi aux
fêtes traditionnelles de la région et
bien sûr à la veille de france italie de
football lyonnais j'ose pas à fait là
bas aussi un pronostic sur place a même
chalon il n'y a pas que le football dans
la vie et à sienne il ya même surtout le
palio cette fête médiévale au cours de
laquelle vont s'affronter ce soir dans
une course folle à cheval autour de
cette carte à del campo les différents
quartiers de la ville
seulement ce soir si elle reçoit aussi
un hôte de marque lionel jospin venus
voir le palio en compagnie du président
du conseil italien romano creux et à la
veille du match france italie ce sommet
amical devient aussi à semer
footballistiques
si tout va bien entre l'italie et la
france en ce moment et qu'on touche au
ballon
les positions deviennent naturellement
inconciliables je suis
nous on répondra me alors oui voilà nous
nous téléphonons de vue que pour l'un
téléphonant à l'autre pour le
réconforter savons pas qui à la veille
du quart de finale avec l'italie donc
l'équipe de france s'est entraînée à
huit clos dans sa retraite de
clairefontaine il n'y a plus
d'inquiétudes sur l'état de santé de
fabien barthez ni de thierry henry yann
lavoix andré germain en bonne santé
aussi quatre ans et demi qu'aimé jacquet
chemine sur un sentier parsemé de ronces
et d'orties
ce sera son 50e match demain la tête de
l'équipe de france et l'on se dit que de
chemin parcouru
très bon chemin il y a quatre ans et
demi cela avait commencé à naples par
une victoire sur les italiens un but de
joker son premier face à un gardien ne
met pas les yuccas balouka deviendra
ensuite le coéquipier de djorkaeff à
l'inter de milan mais il s'inclinera une
nouvelle fois face aux français lors du
tournoi de france
demain les deux amis se retrouveront à
nouveau deux on s'entraîne tous les
matins en sang mais tout mais je crois
que à moi encore plus de déjouer ou de
faire des choses qui kills et honorons
pendant 10 ans 4 ans et demi bien
d'autres amitiés franco italiennes sont
ainsi apparus et si on italie les
français se sont fait beaucoup de
copains ils ont surtout fait beaucoup de
progrès l'italien nous apporte
énormément
si on est à ce niveau de la compétition
doit beaucoup à ces clubs italiens c'est
évident même si nous aussi je pense
alors rapporté quand même quelque chose
les français sont sur deux pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du foot
ils partiront favoris demain face à
l'italie ils joueront pour atteindre une
demi-finale de coupe du monde
un sommet dans une carrière moi je
considère que c'est le match le plus
important de ma carrière parce que c'est
un moyen plus en demi et que c'est
l'objectif premier objectif que je
m'étais fixé avant de débuter cette
coupe du monde ne mange et surtout
l'envi de de gagner parce qu'autrement
je risque d'avoir une année difficile
l'année prochaine à me faire chambrer
tous les jours donc
avec cette petite pirouette deschamps
cache un peu de sa grande détermination
il sait que l'italie n'a jamais perdu un
quart de finale de coupe du monde mais
il se dit aussi que la france touche
presque au but et que le chemin emprunté
depuis quatre ans et demi derrière aimé
jacquet mériterait de se prolonger
et voici l'équipe de france probable qui
jouera demain tels que les spécialistes
la voix est tel que nos indications nous
permettent de vous la montrer ce n'est
pas encore l'équipe officielle mais
c'est en tout cas sans doute la 95 %
celle qui sera sur le terrain demain
après midi au stade de france
l'un des attaquants italiens les plus
redoutés c'est christian vieri qui est
actuellement le meilleur marqueur du
mondial avec cinq buts ex-aequo avec
l'argentin batistuta christian vieri est
âgé de 24 ans il joue actuellement à
l'atlético de madrid
christelle bertrand frédéric pas ce cap
christian vieri n'est pas un italien
comme les autres de par ses origines
d'abord sa mère est française son père
est un ancien joueur professionnel
la carrière du père a conduit toute la
famille viry en australie le football ne
rentrera dans sa vie qu'à l'âge de 12
ans trois ans plus tard christian est
envoyé chez son grand père en italie
histoire de retrouver un peu les racines
et de choisir le football définitivement
christian vieri reste au pays et devient
professionnel et il a toujours la
bougeotte
en sept ans il a connu six clubs l'an
dernier
l'atletico madrid a déboursé 120
millions de francs pour viril attaquant
viry n'est pas non plus un joueur
italien comme les autres quand il touche
la balle il marque même à l'entraînement
sans fioritures sur le terrain il est
aussi avare de confidences aux médias
italiens tous les journalistes et c'est
très difficile avec les vieux baby
que saviez pourquoi on a joué des
et n'est pas parole c'est un jouet que
peut faire jouer
elles n'ont pas l'air rapide puissant
précis depuis le début du mondial il a
marqué cinq buts
une terreur pour les défenseurs un
calvaire pour les gardiens l'équipe de
france avec plusieurs vieilles
connaissances voilà ce qu'il en pense
ce sont de très bons joueurs beaucoup
d'entre eux jouent en italie
cela va être très difficile de les
battre face à la france celui que les
italiens surnomment le muet ne va pas se
gêner pour s'exprimer balocchi joueur
français le plus redouté par les
italiens maintenant c'est sans aucun
doute inédit zidane à marseille où il
est né sa famille attend le match de
demain avec impatience et appréhension
philippe visseyrias angers motte une
maison cossue dans un quartier
résidentiel de la banlieue marseillaise
un cadeau de zine dine à ses parents
loin de la tension qui entoure le match
france-italie smile zidane le père du
surdoué du football français reste sera
vous allez lui téléphoner mais d'ici
demain
non c'est lui qui téléphonent et quel
téléphone ce soir qu'est ce que vous lui
dionne et qui soit solide au poste
solidité du travail des valeurs
inculquées à toute la famille
farid nordine jamel heni là pour un
frère et une soeur qui ont vu s'épanouir
le phénomène zidane sans renier le sens
de la famille
c'est toujours resté le petit frère oui
il a toujours besoin de sa famille il a
toujours besoin de nous avoir au bout du
fil pour savoir comment on va pour
parler de ce qui fait que tu marc
cloutier comme s'ils s'étaient manqués
marc demuth gens me voient et j'ai
besoin que tout le monde m'en garde et
je suis sûr
du béton de la cité de la castellane
dans les quartiers nord de marseille à
la juventus de turin
zinédine s'est accroché à son rêve
contre l'avis de son père
réticent au départ l'école c'était
j'étais quelque chose qui qui n'attirait
pas du tout et je ferai ce qu'à travers
du football avait ici servi de ça pour
pour prouver à mon père que même si
elles paraissent du sud avait il pouvait
lui apporter autre chose un milieu du
sport
la famille zidane c'est que la france
entière attend des miracles de la part
de zine dine
victoire ou défaite eux seront à ses
côtés demain soir quoi qu'il arrive le
joueur du psg
vincent guérin voit sa suspension de six
mois ferme pour dopage annulé par le
tribunal administratif de versailles il
fallait signaler
la décision avait été prise par la
fédération française de football il ya
quelques mois
il ya aussi ceux qui n'apprécient pas le
football et pour qui les soirées
risquait d'être plus tôt londres en ce
mois de juin et de juillet une vingtaine
de théâtres parisiens se sont donc
regroupés pour offrir dix mille places à
moitié prix et ça marche
reportage battus chez william et harry
avec la coupe du monde les théâtres se
voyait mettre la clé sous la porte
ils sont plein tous les soirs
explications les places sont 50% moins
cher une contre attaque foudroyante
décidé par une vingtaine de théâtre
parisien j'évoque la dernière est-elle 4
juillet donc j'ai profité pour voir
cette pièce là je pense que d'ici la fin
du monde pourrait avoir d'autres
d'autres pièces non c'est une bonne
c'est une bonne affaire pour j'ai déjà
vu d'autres matches que j'ai bien aimé
mais je profite de l'opportunité d'avoir
d'aller voir le théâtre moitié prix qui
mon sac pas trop saturé et votre mari
regarde ensemble pas mariés mais ses
supporters viennent voir patrick
chesnais et zabou dans skylight un des
gros succès la saison
privé de match horaire oblige les deux
acteurs réussissent pourtant à suivre le
mondial depuis la scène sous la porte et
des théâtres
c'est un foot de tergnier sucres lents
d'aller sur scène la vie travail quand
j'ai déjà doublé son texte et que fois
non on pense au foot
roméo à lui plus de chance il interprète
un second rôle
en tout une dizaine de minutes sur scène
entre deux interprétations
il peut courir regarder les matchs dans
sa loge
j'ai pas loupé deux buts non je ne crois
pas à un jeu raté trois buts
e
ferdinand est le fils de patrick
chesnais ballon au pied il suit les
rencontres en attendant son père mais il
a l'interdiction de donner le score en
amoureux du ballon rond
l'acteur regarde les matches de retour
chez lui comme quoi tertre et mondiale
ne font pas si mauvais ménage que tout
cela ne nous empêche pas de saluer la
performance de nathalie tauziat qui
jouera la finale du tournoi de tennis de
wimbledon elle a battu en demi-finale et
rêva et rencontrera donc en finale
samedi novotna londres etienne leenhardt
l'après midi commence et à peine sur le
vert gazon du court central de wimbledon
nathalie tauziat venaient d'effacer 73
ans d'histoire avant tel en 1925 seul
suzanne lenglen avait emmené la france
en finale du tournoi anglais je suis
même pas si j'ai pensé à quelqu'un ou
quelque chose j'étais surtout pour moi
c'est une consécration que c'est c'est
c'est tous mes choix que j'ai fait
depuis des pays j'ai commencé à jouer au
tennis il eu dans cette rencontre de
nathalie tauziat laminé dans le premier
set par la bélarusse natasha zvereva si
j'ose à et puis la française remporte à
l'arraché la deuxième manche c jaws a6
avant de s'imposer 6 3 dans le dernier
set dans les fables de la fontaine
nathalie tauziat serait plutôt tortueux
cette expérience m'a dit normalement
l'avant ce moment-là pas pété les plombs
qu'on l'âge données d énormément et je
pense que finalement je suis quelqu'un
qui avait besoin de prendre mon temps et
aujourd'hui voilà j'ai 30 ans et samedi
après midi son everest à elle sera une
vieille connaissance illana novotna tête
de série numéro 3 a battu un peu à la
surprise générale en deux manches 6 4 6
4 la grande favorite ce martina hingis
la tchèque a 29 ans et trois finales
perdues à wimbledon novotna tauzia ou la
finale des revenantes juste le temps de
vous rappeler les principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi la cour de
cassation confirme la peine de six mois
de prison ferme pour bernard s'est tenue
dans la sphère du fossé à bernard tapie
qui est doté notre invité ce soir
ville affaire du sang contaminé vers une
mise hors de cause des trois anciens
ministres laurent fabius
edmond hervé georgina dufoix
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
demain à 20 heures ici même vous
retrouverez béatrice schönberg je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sans
prochaine